turn it off that's what I would say it's
it's it's hard for young people now
because they're hooked they're addicted
if you don't think you're addicted and
I'm talking about anyone from the
highest to the lowest if you don't think
you're addicted then see if you can turn
it off for a
week it got quiet in here didn't it
didn't it get real quiet it's a tool so
we should use it God has blessed us with
free will now is Free Will magnified
free will on steroids you're free to go
in any direction you want it will allow
you and it's not the enemy it's just a m
it's it's just a reflection of our own
free will and and we all want to be
liked but now we want to be lik by 16
million and will now some of us do
anything to be
liked we we used to do anything to be
liked but it was the by the person in
front of you now it's to be like by 16
million people that you don't know